[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
audios out yeah hello everybody welcome
to the Mike Myers verse how is everybody
doing today thank you for joining us
I'll do interest first shall we so right
above my head is Brandon Winfrey our
lovely wonderful DM who actually put him
GM who will be guiding us through this
adventure do you have any words that you
would like to say Brandon just to screw
Chloe okay to my way is it north it's up
to the left to the right is a lot of
Pierce who will be one I'm gonna say
anybody's characters although I think
it's may be probably pretty obvious who
some of us so a lot of Pierce is here
joining us as well and then below Alana
and to my left or right is Elliot Du
Barry you may know him from Internet
today happy to be here terrified I know
I think all of us I don't know about
Lana but we were discussing this before
we're all little nervous because this is
Brandon's kind of like learning about
the Mike Myers situation this is my
first time any know well you you had to
come up with a whole Mike Myers world
this seems like a weird time to be
asking this and maybe I should have
asked this from the jump but why are we
doing this
why not okay so here's the story about
Mike Myers first the reason that we're
doing this first of all
Brandon has done a lot of these TT RPGs
at hyper RPG for charity and I love just
doing really goofy stuff on my channel
and I always wanted to do stuff for
charity but I was never I never knew how
to it seemed like there was a lot
involved and I was really nervous about
screwing it up and stuff like that and
then one day I can't remember who had
this idea but I think it might have been
me actual
myself I think like Brandon you know we
should do can we do a TT RPG were just
all of Mike Myers different characters
and brands like yeah let's do it
and he pushed me to finally get all of
this sorted out and we're actually
supporting a very very good charity
today feeding America they work
year-round but currently they are
supporting people who are struggling to
eat in this this caught in during the
corona virus during this pandemic and
it's you know I remember I actually
heard about feeding America a while ago
I'm really fortunate that stream Labs
makes this whole thing work too but
feeding America they were like somebody
was posting about them on reddit and
people a lot of people when they're just
like down on their luck if they couldn't
eat during college they would go to
these these they have these Cod the food
banks sorry there's like food banks and
they would just be handing out food to
people and and and it saved a lot of
lives just people who couldn't who
couldn't afford food during college and
now like a lot of people are struggling
during this crisis and they've been
doing really really really good work and
I will say like I feel very confident
and I'm always very like about charities
but I feel very confident about feeding
America yeah I've had a few things where
I've done stuff for charity and then
someone's been like that charity is bad
and I've been like [ __ ] like it can be
like more complicated than you would
think but for the most part is very
positive and fun and I just want to off
the bat tell the people who are watching
on my youtube channel the link to donate
is in the description if you donate to
me on super chat for the stream I am
going to say do not do that I would much
prefer that you donated to charity you
just can't do it directly through
through YouTube so it's just the link in
the description it says donate yes but
they're on that exactly and there is a
way they owe me as well it's just it's
just stream lag stream Labs comm slash
tips flash sky dart and whatever you
donate donate there I know it sounds
like you're tipping me I promise you
it's just going to redirect you to a
charity page if you go to it there's
also a link that you can just click on
so you'd have to type in right below me
under donate or right next to donate it
is donate if you click donate it will
take you to the to the patient
okay yes did we already make $5 am I
reading that correctly well I will I did
it everyone yeah I donated $5 I mean
yeah I'm not gonna tell you yeah we want
we made five it doesn't matter where it
came from so Brandon will explain
we have incentives as you can see right
up there we have like $5 $10 $15 $20 for
it sir and when you donate you can
actually influence the whole course of
the story I love Brandon explain cuz
he's done this million times said he'll
exactly explain better okay so just I'll
explain the whole kind of situation in
case people are new DT RPGs hey welcome
thank you everyone for being here really
appreciate it it's gonna be a lot of fun
we're gonna be using a system called the
tales from the loose system tales from
the loose the loop system very very
simple you you have attributes each of
them will have different attributes four
of them no roll a few D sixes and if
they get a six that's a success that's
obviously deeper than that four but for
our purposes we're just gonna have fun
and really oh yeah did your keyboard is
so powerful yeah it's a problem I
actually took all the keys off like a
year ago and put dampeners under them so
this is as loud as it originally
I respect okay so what do we everyone
should yes in note of like if they get
dice or rerolls now just go through the
incentives real quick Wow look at that
beautiful flag I'll go through the
incentives real quick to kind of explain
what people are giving whenever you are
tipping a thank you so much for sporting
charity make sure you do the hash tag on
what you want to do so for instance you
give five bucks hashtag dice then you're
gonna say a player that you want to give
an extra dice to what this means is if
normally they're gonna roll three dice
now on their next roll they can roll
four simple as that $10 rear oh they can
reroll the whole thing
it's just just to specify which person
you're gonna give it to you for $15 is
the combat system we're gonna be
fighting people it's gonna be brutal
there's gonna be blood
you know I keep forgetting this is not
Warhammer you can just add any Mike
Meyers themed enemy to the game and
they're gonna have to fight it I'll
bring that up somehow for 20 bucks you
can give them a weapon am i clear
yeah weapon for instance if you want to
give them the penis pump from awesome
powers you can do that he used that as a
weapon 20 bucks that's an auto kill on
an enemy $25 you can make any of these
people a new character for ten minutes a
new Mike Meyers character so if you're
like I really want to love guru
you can tip to make someone to love guru
for ten minutes and in the swap back and
then for the big cojones oh my god
marble for the big enchilada on the
burrito supreme could do a GM move for
$50 and you could just make something
happen you could just guide it and and
I'll have to adjust and go for it it's
the most brutal chaotic one and it
messes up my beautiful story but to be
honest I don't need your holes help
because I didn't write much so I'm
looking to you guys to like fill this
sucker up please do my work for me yes
yeah exactly how could I the audience
into making my content if they pay and
they pay to do it and I will say with
all that stuff just like look keep
within the mind of pg-13 don't do
anything you know what is out of bounds
not doing that voice
I think it's the default in case you
guys don't know this about me I have
seen so few movies in my lifetime that I
am not familiar with what the Love Guru
even is we all collectively forgot it I
actually tweeted about this the other
day we all forgot that John Oliver is a
main character in this film oh I've
never even seen this before okay yeah
well just so love guru equals Russian
accent got it
I can do that down you that's okay
all right so I think that's it's
basically what I need to know Chloe do
you have any other things before we get
into this I did make a good point which
is that for people who've never seen
Brandon on anything before you seem fine
to me
oh no it's adorable it's it's it's one
of his greatest charms okay so wait what
was that did we get a $10 donation clue
we did from Tracy Anderson Thank You
Tracy
but there was no there was no request
that we also got one from Magel tiger
who donated $5 to say Adam is best sad
Pikachu I agree that must be directed
Ilana no beyond Kovach yes he is a good
set Pikachu misses facts there we go
yeah if you guys just want a tip
obviously can get it too there are goals
there aren't overall goals so if we just
wait so how much to pay to change
characters they're all on screen here
right yeah five dollars per character
okay yeah it should be on the screen
also yeah I have to say if you guys
wouldn't mind sharing this on your page
as well or tell telling some friends who
might be interested was like like yeah I
know who everyone has a superfan of
Shrek friend you know what I mean like
if you share with them that would be
okay don't get this the only way you can
get new Shrek content and that was
you're gonna be doing that I'll do my
best
Oh girls have layers layers okay
Brennan you got it sorry you chose like
the biggest drink it makes you look so
tired
it does look huge makes it look like
we're sponsored by a company called
truly oh that's thank you for bringing
that up Chloe because what um we're
gonna have goals so at like a hundred
bucks Cam's gonna have to do that or
someone's gonna have to do that dr. evil
monologue I thought cam was dr. evil we
we have plans we have I need an actor to
do it 20 50 bucks Chloe's gonna sell out
she has to give Doritos and Pepsi an ad
for free
[Laughter]
500 bucks we're all gonna do a dramatic
reading of all star so if we can
internet for 200 bucks right now now
we're all ready to get into what's going
I hate that I can't see you Chloe
sorry I know I was gonna tell you like
if I had known there is a way that you
can virtual cam will let you but it's
still I know what I yeah it would I
would have to undo my snap camera and
then yeah filters I'm not using snap
camera on the stream
I um leaves it on zoom so I can do
stupid faces on when I'm drunk I'm
Clinton playing jackbox with people
mm-hmm okay are we ready for this is the
world ready yeah will they ever be let
me bring up my nose okay we go towards
the sky it's a beautiful sky and it's
because it's a Canadian sky over there
hand down and who do we see sitting
alone on a hilltop looking out over a
beautiful city of Toronto which has
buildings and sidewalks like other
cities do I don't know Canada that we
already have it you already have a
donation for a weapon wait
damn hold your lawsuits and a free roll
Ilana you're gonna get a lot of stuff
well keep track of that give me paw all
right just make sure to keep track
sessional my weapon to this we paying
down and we see semi-retired Canadian
Mike Myers just gazing out upon his
creation and that is obviously mr.
Elliott DeBary and he's just there he
just got off he tucked his kids into bed
he's a domestic man now pause pause boss
we got a $50 donation already from goats
kill ghosts either ghosts kill act or
it's a ghost skill
I'm not eating right thank you go skill
thank you much
was it a GM or just a tip I mean unless
ghosts kill wants to take over already
I don't like it get rid of it terrible
actually you're in space actually well
okay uh we see a young Elliot Du Barry
not Elliot's okay Mike Ryan I'm actually
not very young I'm 56 years old but a
very accomplished life I was born on May
25th 1963 which makes me a Gemini yeah
uh which makes sense considering my
creative output throughout my life no
he's saying this to nothing mr. Mike
Myers quarantine has been very lonely
and in the sky he actually sees a glint
and that first he thinks it's a shooting
star so he makes a wish now what wish do
you make hmm you know I wish I could
make one more Austin Powers movie but
just the whole comedy scene has changed
so much since the early 2000s that I
just you know wouldn't it be nice it
would can you give me a heart check
maybe there is a way to do that no we're
not just a 1 4 4 4 role
okay so there will never be another
Austin Powers movie made sorry about
that
but you see this glint and what you
actually don't it starts getting closer
and closer and closer until you realize
this is no shooting star this is a UF
o-- an unidentified flying object and
out of this comes a smaller speck of
light at first you might think it's a
ghost but then you're like oh it's
probably an alien says it's from space
and then what it does is it Sears right
here into your head and just slowly
burns into your mind and goes into your
brain mmm he docked a Manhattan
yes and then right on in and you black
out screen blacks out really put the
black out screen on that I know you
could have prepared this she was like I
want to play Bohemian Rhapsody a long
time and I'm like no and your eyes kind
of flutter open and then you see
and finally you hear off in the distance
the voice of something that sounds like
an ogre and what do they say what are
you doing in a swamp
I got a Scottish so it has to be Irish
uh I'm sorry about that too but I can
only do one of them so it's gonna have
to be that beautiful yes you you wake up
Mike Myers and you see Shrek this
character that you have voiced just
lording over you in the distance is that
Shrek the character I played and the bow
was it the 2001 movie Shrek and then the
2004 movie Shrek 2 and then the 2007
movie Shrek the third oh my god he's
definitely looking off-screen that's my
characters
okay notice Shrek instructs very angry
and you also look around and you see two
other characters as well okay I see
someone who's just in a backwards hat
it's definitely not back rock words hat
but also I'm not Irish
so front words hat and then you also see
I'm in a real groovy get up you go up
and walk to them you're all in a circle
now oh my god oh my god
my character Wayne from during my 1989
to 1995 run on Saturday Night Live and
the 1992 film Wayne's World excellent
and it's Austin Powers 1999 film 1997
Austin Powers international man of
mystery the 1999 follow up Austin Powers
the Spy Who shagged me and the 2002
Austin Powers in Goldmember in which I
played three roles what's everybody
doing in the swamp you guys get a ring
Mike Myers open this flip phone it's a
razor it's real cool yep
open it up and you see a handsome
British gentleman there it's a swamp so
it's very realistic
I just like to get into character good
evening Michael Myers
I'm basil exposition oh is that you mr.
powers
my god it's good to see you you look so
your teeth are beautiful now well it is
2020 your teeth now apparently even if
your English
so it is hmm but we have a mission for
you mr. powers and all oh sheesh Rex
here as well wait and see me retired
Michael Myers well welcome to my six
chaps in my six no seven whichever
agency I'm a part of my god mr. powers
you brung you didn't say in my 69 I'm
proud of you
what do you do what does it all mean
basil oh my god you're I'll do it in my
[ __ ] swamp am i dead good to see you
Shrek we're actually inside Mike Myers's
mind that's right an alien like one just
visited you last night and he actually
planted a neuro bomb inside your brain
now you have to collect fragments of
your many many characters and
personalities or else your brain would
explode in a psychic energy blast and
murder
living life forms on planet Earth crikey
puzzle the first thing you must do say
crikey
oh yeah the first thing you must do is
save a princess from a town but get this
there's a dragon get on with it
chop chop Bassel out wait wait hold on
bat what sorry quick question just a mo
where is the tower where are we going oh
maybe I can help with that I wish I'm a
pig what is this what I'm not hopping
pop from the movie Shrek oh yeah really
trying to find I have a list of Shrek
quotes and I'm trying to if there are
quotes that are related to where the
tower is but all I can find is
it's time to pack up your toothbrush and
jammies you're the new king of far far
away
we do have heard in my french-canadian
but what the heck is going on
who's this pig oh it is me did you
mention far far away Shrek
yes is that a Caribbean patois I hear in
your voice oh yes I'm from London
yeah okay yes so my home it just got hot
and puffed and blown so instead I will
take you to see Palace Palace place if
you help me build it home okay Shrek
what's everybody doing in my swamp
I'm sorry Shrek Shrek we will soon evil
swamp it's so sexy about it what do you
need so we need from us like how what do
you want you know I just want to help
people but first you know after the
missions done we can build me a little
house of hay and why is this happening
to me Canadian actor Mike Myers I think
you're dreaming I believe the Basile
exposition said it was an alien life
form that's why not why not other
Canadian actors like Jim Carrey Jim
they're like Gary's movies with too much
okay okay well follow me in my swamp I
guess we better follow that pig take
Shrek maybe someone else can convince
you to leave your swamp okay well that
was a prompt I think for someone to try
to convince me to stay in the swamp
which maybe you have to Rolf all as this
is a ttop she is that
who does I have to fix tonight buck
because he's going ham right now in the
chat for no reason I didn't know he
could do that and then somebody has to
commit like I just feel like it's on
brand that I can't just leave the swamp
without being angry you know it just
seems wrong thank you
all right hold on is this Shrek the
Shrek from the first Shrek or is it
shrek from Shrek the third or he's
already found Cameron Diaz
I've not seen Shrek the third this is
pre Shrek Lord Farquaad is still yes
wait has has Wayne met Tia Carrere yet
why no no no okay okay it's everyone is
pre everything I thought Valerie's
return to the the future yet what's
happening my girl Cassandra well this is
all in my brain I should stop asking so
many questions yeah this is you
imagining this day do you do yet
the god dang aliens gave me brain cancer
and well I guess we better call the pig
all right Knight bot has been he's been
quieted ok I gotta cut that [ __ ] yeah
someone has to convince rectally oh
listen Shrek I could tell you you know
from experience your this might be
difficult for you to digest but I am you
you are me sort of and telling you if
you leave that swamp there's about 500
million dollars in box office revenue
waiting for you on the other side I
don't know what dollars are well I think
about what do you like Shrek peace and
quiet
well imagine millions of that enough
peace and quiet to last several
lifetimes can you roll for that
yeah can you roll from heart you're
trying to appeal to her all right what's
uh how many heart rolls do I have I
think it's one of yours I have four so
[Laughter]
we've only got this one life you know
what I'm saying I'm saying you can leave
but you can always come back I just want
peace and quiet that's gonna be I feel
like she just like try to try to mind
maybe quiet is always in your head
all right roll for mine khlo thank me I
think wait - OH - OH
is is pulled by this beautiful message
from Wayne and you're right it says
always in my mind
mm-hmm shall we go get Shrek satisfied
sure all right so let's just everybody
get out of my [ __ ] swamp let's get
this done so I can come back to my swamp
follow me okay so you guys are on the
streets and you passed by many fields of
wheat and windmills and other fantasy
elements Toronto sure is beautiful isn't
it as you guys are crossing three Onion
field and it's so many claps you can't
hear anything else sounds like some sort
of hoofed animal you come through and
you see an entire Legion of knights and
you seal or fart
fitting horse Brandon are you reading
that you're reading that the the things
right are you reading the donations no I
need you to tell me them I know I'm
trying to well it's funny enough
somebody did donate and request Lord
Farquaad I'm gonna go oh we have another
donation thank you for Jack's donations
real quick yeah so we have two extra
dice two extra rolls for Alana we roller
dice rerolls or extra dice okay
appreciate that yeah two rolls for Lana
we have she gets a weapon which is a
gold member
we request gold he gets the weapon which
is a human being
well I assume it is a member that is
gold alright so now I wanna at any point
in combat you can use a gold member to
get an auto kill okay Patrick for an
enemy which is actually already as I am
aware in the in the story so Patrick if
you wanted to go ahead and re request an
enemy you would like to see making my
job harder thanks Chloe no okay okay
okay we donate to good causes it makes
it inconvenient for the DM and DM
beautiful thank you guys so much for
donating by the way are we ending up
we're getting actually work 100 we oh we
passed 165 thank you everyone
wait we're at 165 yeah [ __ ] okay then
we're gonna we're gonna clock back to
our $100 but that means we're chugging
along on our two hundred and fifty
dollar widgets or Chloe fellow first
things first I'm the realest yeah thanks
I got a nice for me too and from weight
from the other Winfrey brother nice oh
yeah my frozen chat shout out to Adam I
look like him now that I have a thing
going on
so alright that thing we caught up yeah
yeah I think we're all caught up so
you've written down golden or I wanna
husband
everyone's down Goldmember and to
rerolls yeah and I have a well you have
a dice you have an extra dice diced 2
times extra dice yes and I have a
beautiful okay so you enter through you
coming along the road you see this
Allegiant of knights and you see Lord
Farquaad just on top ok looks down and
sees this little merry band of misfits
you there Shrek me do you think maybe is
compensating for something
of course not if you mean my member I
assure you it is gold same and he winks
a camera and he's lifted off he's put
down what are you doing outside of your
swamp shrek brennan you can't just stand
up we do know how tall you are it's okay
he's getting into character and i really
appreciate it Brandon's five six is
ready I had no idea okay
the question was why did I leave my
swamp they wouldn't leave me alone and
we're trying to help some would just get
out of my way huh you're trying to help
the princess laughable the pig is a
princess no no there's a who are you oh
I'm strangely attracted what is this
mojo is it witchcraft some say some say
God defeated us which in all the guards
draw their blades and you just have four
nights
at you now in order I want each of you
to tell me what you do with one of these
nights so the first person they're
rushing to because of all this mojo just
spilling out of his body Austin Powers
what do you do I like what do I have you
got sweet guitar licks okay you don't
shop I'm gonna say that's a body move
now
so I want to resolve all this at the
same time you body chop a you judo chop
Wayne what do you do I think I just I
try to get them just like chill out you
know what I mean just like job okay okay
so that seems like a like a body heart
all right strike what are you gonna do
I'm going to fought cup it and throw it
nice art cup and throw yeah good all
right
and Mike Myers what are you gonna do
well listen I my comedy is obviously a
very physical profession and I I've
risen to the upper echelons of both
Canadian and American comedy and that
often involves you know the body
I'm not 56 years old now and my strength
isn't so great though I don't know if
these if these uh CGI Knights know
anything about the virus but I'm gonna
try to cough on one of them wait my
heart as my as my turn to get people to
chill out is that heart or my or bottom
that's a heart okay okay you roll you
roll a body can we have a request to
change character oh and the next extra
dice for Elliott so write that remember
that Elliott so we have it we have a
request for Cameron to play fat bastard
three women get and my belly yeah yeah
yeah gonna eat you up
wait do it yeah so all of a sudden
there's a glitch almost
there's a glitch in the matrix okay in
Austin Powers morphs into fat bastard
and you tried to do what - the night I
know I just feel like I've been upstaged
frankly except that you maybe can do the
Scottish and I just sound Irish you can
do any accent for Austin Powers is 3 but
bode for fat bastard has to be off the
charts ok you because someone tipped for
it - I'll give you 5 dice for this how
did you how come your body's 3 in your
tech is I feel like Austin Powers body
as you like need 1 6 to succeed right
yes oh my god another huge donation from
risky ruski you donated $50 thank you
risky thank you thank you so much and
thank you to everybody else by the way
in dark Wraith and DJ silver who has
donated as well and by the way we are
50% of the way to of we already are 50
yeah and let me also explain two really
quick we are actually nearing the end of
the campaign we have a subscriber oh
it's dad subscribe hey Dad same audio
and I don't know why but yeah so we are
close to the end of the campaign on
stream labs I think let me actually pull
up these yeah they hit they're about to
hit the overall goal so if they hit
15,000 were that would be amazing let me
see those alright now with our
assistance so it's like three hundred
and fifty bucks away
basically and then we would be hitting
the goal for feeding America's coasts
months yeah that would be amazing so
let's see if we can get there it says
500 but I have to look exactly how much
we we're way but yes thank you oh thank
you for the subscription thank you
hello was that fifty or donation to GMO
or was it just a tough no it was just at
it was just somebody being very kind and
generous they're letting you take I
think they all trust you Brandon I know
there's a there's an auteur vision that
I you know exudes so thank you for that
all right all right back the fat bastard
yeah
crabs someone and he come in at one in
mine and you start to eat him something
you think what's actually weird as you
actually feel your your earth right your
girth is the same as Austin Powers so
it's not the you don't have that same
like jaw strength and you actually just
split some of your mouth open and see
good it was there then you think you
know you ask people how you got those
scars in the future we're on the hype
train guys train I don't know but it
says thinking about Mike Myers as
whenever someone does something bad so
we go to you how do you roll
kind of talk this night down Oh me oh
yeah who is you and you have an extra
dice when you use that clue I would use
it okay earn them okay so I'm talking
the night down like listen we don't need
to fight like this we can just work
together you know what I mean like wait
why am i New York
I just want to get the I don't know we
could just all get together we could
just work this out to get I don't
understand why we've got a fight you
know why don't we just like listen to
some sick music together the night you
see stumbles back a little bit your
words piercing into the central core
text of his empathy
you know node and role for me okay I got
one
I don't know what happened here I got
another one I got two sixes you got two
sixes that's an exceeding success that's
something you've never felt in your life
hello so this is rolling the knight is
overwhelmed with compassion and he takes
his blade you're right good and he stabs
the night that was that fat bastard was
trying to eat just right in the throat
blood spews everywhere it's basically
The Shining it's pouring down go over to
Shrek Shrek what do you do how do you do
this how do I throw my fault
okay that's what I establish they do I
literally it's really loud I fought in
my hand okay but I grabbed it
huge hands Shrek has big hands the
ladies room and and I just kept it and I
just throw it right in his face like
sort of like kamehameha type thing you
know like it's like the real push
kamehameha command me
exactly how many do I have to roll with
my to mr. dice is that like you don't
have to you can save them if you want
honestly what I'll let you even roll
them and then if you don't get any you
can roll another extra that's very nice
okay reroll I have four for body anyway
so I'm rolling okay
I'm using my fall and that gives me a
total of twenty I got five four six five
so you got a six yeah you succeeded I
succeeded yes you basically you through
it like a really good pitcher Barry
Bonds and it just hits this night in the
face and what happens to him I like you
decide I go how you like to smell of em
onions and he immediately vomits all
over himself and it's so acidic because
they just don't eat very good for the
night in the castle that he also like
decomposes oh I was I'm gonna come over
with a cup before it right before that
happens is feel like if you're gonna
spew spewing this Chloe everywhere all
over all over the mobile you know so yes
as as you're just cupping this dude out
of a you're getting a cup of his vomit
Chlo ironic for you you you see the the
vomit that has spewed out because it's
burning and all you can see as he kind
of goes down like the wild witch of the
west and it's just that's great and then
we go to Mike Myers who what did you do
again Jesus Christ that man is Dad
integrated
look at this angle of this Marva PG
pg-13 sort of guy this is that's pretty
r-rated how many more these nights are
left don't you think this is one point
there's just one more oh geez I I'm just
gonna pretend to sneeze on him so he
thinks I'm sick and he runs all right
okay that's mine
that's that's smart alright I got for
mine dice plus one extra dice I I think
yeah you can use that guys alright let's
check it out oh geez we got one six one
six er oh you got a six to you in just a
car yeah what does he do what does he do
well he's uh pretty confused cuz I mean
like we've established the castles
disgusting you got sneezed on all the
time this wasn't you know he's pretty
used to that kind of thing his friend
just [ __ ] himself and died right next to
him well you know [ __ ] whatever but uh
yeah he's pretty scared of this COFF cuz
this guys wearing different clothes he's
got like shoes on his feet and he's got
a cell phone he bolts you have defeated
my Knights but can you defeat oh my days
hold on timeout okay we're timing out
well we have another donation that is
requesting oh we have oh we have - oh
boy okay so we have a $50 donation from
Daria who is requested that general IDI
finish Finnick fennec Oh glorious
bastards joins as an NPC Ally and then
also
Camryn's now goldmember's fast
approaching our actual goal we are we're
fifty-five dollars away from that we
have another $20 tip from all from
Carrie another donation I'm hip I'm hip
with it could do could do good thank you
guys so much for all the tips we're
gonna resolve this and then we'll get
into our fun goals that we you guys hit
for us
but first cam your Goldmember now and
then do they want just the day if there
was a GM tip to just have this general
join them correct yes yes yeah which
would be you technically Brendon yes I'm
gonna do some research oh is that his
voice okay I can I can wrap that in like
one of my lesser known characters okay
so far quad comes up to you and he
brings out two blades
he just leaps and he's quick
you see he's small but he's quick those
are only other benefits as you when
you're short you're agile you can get on
planes well so this is the only benefit
he has so it comes at all of you with
the strike first thing he does is he
tries to stab Goldmember you ask blitz
into now a gold member what do you did
gold member
yes well I'm very flexible you she inch
in wears from the Netherlands we do yoga
every morning I'm going to your station
to move my legs out of the way over my
shoulders okay so roman romeo body
please which i see it would be fourth of
them and thank you so much it's not you
it's Alex who's donated $60 thank you so
much we need the goal let me see if I
can actually extend
five dollars was easy
let's see if we can hit the goal of the
campaign now that makes me so thank you
guys so much we've already raised my
voice should have made more goals great
and we have some cheers as well thank
you daredevil like a [ __ ] is a hit on as
we established don't do a hit
what did you say it's not what what
crazy like a fox which is not a phrase
to hit on someone oh yeah crazy like a
fox and I'm like I'm pretty sure you hit
on like no that's not what that means
extend this guy's okay
how can you roll can you roll me body so
you're doing something like this right
like doing the stretches getting over
dodging give me a 6 when that make him
better
like at stretching another request you
don't do it right now but that was the
requesting someone's slower than what I
had planned unfortunately I have failed
disaster has struck all right he cuts
off the goldmember's leg ah are you
thinking - Bartok oh my god we have
another huge donation a hundred dollars
from Michael theory who's due who says
representing Internet today fans thank
you Michael thank you guys so much
oh my gosh how many so many wonderful
donations I'm gonna see if I can sort
this out oh that's so great we might
actually okay so you I'm just safer for
brevity and time what do you guys want
to do to Farquaad
Alana you have a gold medal I don't
think I want to use my gold member on
being that they were mentions of dragons
earlier I don't feel like I want to
waste that so what am I gonna do to
Farquaad
I don't remember what canonically I can
I just like really insult him
so I I'm gonna I'm gonna go out of my
way to you know use my jaw think he's
compensating for something line and be
like alright look at his dumb castle why
is he so small compared to how big that
has just a lot of install top to bottom
you're really short great can you roll
me a mine
okay mind oh okay Oh Shrek Wow such
things well you are short I can't
control my height that is true but it
doesn't make it any less relevant right
now
Oh again can't be Scottish it's just
Irish it's like I'm on tinder again
you're a little [ __ ] so that's not on
me my truly great job good job taking
out the king the sexy Pig is back now
come with me
OS you have Goldmember now we have
another $50 donation oh my god don't
worry there's no requests thank you so
much Adam we have a $5 donation dice for
Brandon and Brandon in the fight if not
give to random oh they're gonna give the
guys also I would like to say with that
we have hit the fifteen thousand dollar
goal for feeding America's kovin
response fund but they need it are you
telling me we hit I will say we can
obviously bill the charity did not end
no absolutely every dollar is very
helpful for them also Elias you got a
you got another dice so you have a
reroll in a dice I got five dice now yes
we're solid Wow alright sounds sounds
great fight us let's go follow me okay
okay pick kind of sounds like the the
sprockets character I used to thirty
night live you come across a giant
castle and it's it's surrounded by a
moat but for time there's a bridge and
standing kam can give me the voice one
more time think of a game big handlebar
moustache yeah hello chaps yep you're
come to take down the dragon the
greatest beast of all I guess I guess we
have they put a tumor in my brain and I
need to kill the dragon or else I die
oh we do actually and frankly it makes
me uncomfortable being around so many
Americans right now that's fair old chap
I don't blame you
I assume you laughs a lot not sure about
well here's the situation I have a game
plan how we're gonna attack this
situation there's Nazis inside and
there's a Nazi dragon Victor says what
Nazi dragons oh my god but there's two
things I hate Nazis and Nazi dragons
well then you're on the right please
check our dates so here's the situation
I think we should just storm right up in
there huh we have another oh my gosh
thank you it's not you it's Alex's dad
donated another $50 thank you Louie I
pick I can choose I don't do you want to
be the GM for a second god no we asked
you for a very good reason Brandon do
you want to go on this mission with me
defeat the Nazi dragon who's guarding
the Nazi gold
yeah a Nazi dragon oh my god giant
swastika band and everything it's crazy
I don't know who made that for him Wow
yeah I think we should probably do
something about that seeing as I have a
brain tumor it's gonna explode unless we
don't what do you guys do um so we're at
the bridge you're at the bridge all you
have to do is walk in and find a dragon
and save the princess that's I say we
walk on in maybe a little quietly so the
dragon doesn't hear us so we're doing
stealth checks okay
sure does that mean all of us are just
gonna go so well
anyone can do however they roll it what
would Shrek do you know he could be a
Nazi sympathizer I have an idea this
dragon is dragon it loves it loves gold
correct yeah he loves gold
he likes to steal gold correct yeah well
you're looking at a guy who's a
seven-time MTV Movie Awards winner and I
happen to have all of those popcorn
trophies aadmi right now they're very
shiny you know look I was nominated
seven times for the Kids Choice Awards
never one kind of [ __ ] if you asked
me Mike Meyers kind of just
automatically pulled a stealth actor
like ten years ago
oh yeah that's true i stealthily uh you
know walked away from showbiz quite a
while ago I'm pretty stealthy but I
think it might be worth the go if we
tempt this dragon out of its lair with
my seven MTV Movie Award trophies that I
have a at all times this idea perhaps
the other one of you should should
should plan a trap to capture the dragon
undefeated somehow when it's drawn out
okay you're presenting all of your
awards I have an idea I have an idea
sorry this way no Chloe have an idea
both of us okay so I put on like a sexy
paint bra and I'm like you're Wayne yes
and I say listen I got this all right so
um just trust me on this I know what I'm
doing so right now we see Wayne putting
on a sexy pink bra over my shirt and I
take my pants off and I'm wearing tighty
whities okay okay
Shrek two wing strike and Shrek is
really just and still just annoys bond
even my swamp but I feel like the plan
has potential I feel like the gold is a
really good idea on behalf of Mike Myers
what does shrek want to do to a dragon I
don't remember what happens in the film
I feel like I of all people should know
best how they defeated that dragon but I
don't know it was it was flooding donkey
okay
can i what if I use Goldmember again so
Irish I can't do Scottish but I'm just
it's not gonna work
what in a seductive way I'm gonna play
my gold member to try to hit on the
dragon so I'm like look look I know that
I'm not sexy I don't have tits like
Wayne I can't do any of this we're still
not sure if Shrek is a Nazi sympathizer
or not but I just want to go back to my
swamp so Goldmember I smell that the
dragon will know I'm going to send
Goldmember out in his most leather daddy
outfit possible yeah she's right Boyd I
love this plan
Austin Powers do you want to do anything
oh right um also I'm also Austin Powers
right uh yes well hmm I what is gold
members accent by the way cam it's Dutch
it's not all Dutch I've no idea what I'm
doing it's crazy right Sean Connery I've
done so many accents throughout my
career it's sort of what I'm known for
it's this isn't one of them though
there's actually a little-known 90s film
in which I did play an Irish person so
okay I'll take it actually it does make
some sense that Shrek might be Irish
appreciate that okay actually a lot
Alana can you do Liverpool because
because Mike Myers dad was from
Liverpool I know they do lots of like
noise yeah history you do lots of like
that's great you just want to sound like
a Beatle it's tough one though I'm alone
I'll figure it out I've heard it enough
recently that I'll get that accents to
octopus's garden
okay all set Mike Myers
put out sorry your strudel
you'll get Choice Awards about we'll do
all the dragon out where's Chloe I'm
right here
I went to go retrieve a prop Oh got it
okay
okay so we're rolling on Elliot first
yes so Elliot you're gonna roll for I
think that's do you think that's a heart
or ba are a mind or attack it's a tech
because you're please see that's a tech
that's an item oh geez I only have two
dice for a tech roll but you have dice
in the bank you have like five dice you
can add to it so you can roll those two
if you don't hit a six just burn the
rest of them you know okay well I'll
start with the two let's have a look-see
nope no sixes I'll try two more of my my
extra dice okay Chad he might need some
help
uh yeah no more sixes there either two
more of your extra days oh yeah I guess
I could do it you know I had such good
luck from like 1990 to 2005 and the last
the last 15 years or so haven't been
whoo I acquired a lot of weight when you
have a successful movie career you get a
lot of dice let's do two more your
fingers is a big moment no we have a
wait guys we have a wait guys again
whose weapon is it
well no no choice on who gets it but
it's a sign master from so I married an
axe murder yeah I think I always have a
one-hit kill but I think my one hit
killed my Goldmember which I just tried
to play doesn't work unless Elliot's
plan works yes I think this dragon might
know that these uh these MTV Movie
Awards they're not really gold no real
call to spring
they look like gold but you see a dragon
pokets the one head out
remember those awards and you see a puff
of smoke and the smoke forms into a
swastika oh it's a Nazi dragon Christ
Chloe what does Wayne do with the bra
[Music]
that's the dance and I dance for the
dragon and distract the dragon I can't
see you right now there was a visual get
a bra no I did not get a bra no but I
did do the dance okay beautiful that I
feel like can you give me a body check
oh yeah oh yeah okay shoot well how's my
body how's my body doing though three
all right and then do I have one extra
dice actually so I'm going to use that
all right okay so see the dragon a
little bit these dragons wearing
lipstick Nazi lipstick mmm the best kind
sold in all Macy's across America and
then tentatively kind of slowly steps
out and finally comes right up she's
sexy Wayne now what do you do what do
you do Shrek what I've already summoned
my Goldmember right yes you got any more
of that gas left and I just stopped my
video accidentally what I meant to do
was hang on this is really important you
guys are gonna need just wait a second
really important content um here we go
okay there we go done and then um
so I've got my gold member here and
we've got two points of seduction so I
bring out my gold member and he's you
know in character as what would appeal
the most to a Nazi dragon so he's like
I'm trying to think of what donkey
sounds like talking my brain really
wants to write so just don't be a white
woman imitating a black man who is
saying you know some PewDiePie [ __ ]
about Jesus what you're telling me to do
here which I feel is fair thank you so
I'll just go standard you know what I'm
gonna do
oh my god hey like talk to me about your
favorite things about Germany how do you
feel about like all of those highways we
built sound like a horse yeah that's
better
excellent yeah I love it my cat is like
what the hell are you doing this dragon
just cuddles right up next to gold
member who is intimidating donkey who is
imitating sorry who is imitating a white
girl who is pro-nazi the puddle what
does donkey do in this situation so I'm
being cuddled up too right um right
there you know I'm gonna make it real
simple Universal oh my god like should I
like scratch your back do you like do
you want me to like give you a massage
just like you've had a tough day it's
really hard everyone's angry at Nazis
you know I
oh it's a dog yeah alright see you all
Nazis so you're scratching this dragons
back yeah with my hoops with your hose
and the hose real quick just snap the
vertebrae on the back and the back snaps
in half and the Nazi dragon just
dissolves into paper propaganda that
distributes across the lands I was
hoping to [ __ ] the dragon so that's a
huge bummer okay wow I did not see that
coming
so that we there's another glitch in the
matrix lot of glitches and the Dragons
there again and you [ __ ] the dragon and
it's a long scene that takes 39 minutes
and then you get tired and then the
dragon dies wait Mass Effect style or
what are we saying god of war style
there's lots of broken pots Oh absolute
okay okay yeah I feel good about it
fast forward 39 minutes this dragons
exhausted it's got a headache
so it flies away and then you see a
young Cameron Diaz yeah and she walks
out oh my god I was in the holiday the
best rom-com of all time you guys I mean
I would disagree about that I would say
so I'm married so I marry an axe
murderer is actually the best romantic
comedy of all time and you know it's
crazy I made so I married an axe
murderer in 1993 the same year I made
Wayne's World 2 it's a real banner year
for young Mike Meyers oh stop it
oh it was only 30 years old time so
pretty great here's a here's a perfect
you guys a parfait and when what is it
what's a parfait that's some North
American sort of dessert yes
it's yogurt granola it's a great treat
for mid-morning okay do you love the
layers and as soon as you touch it did
someone just say Leia's yeah they did
intrigued by the layers Shrek's I sheets
up out of its head I don't know I love
Monsters Inc though it's found the world
is all around
that's my out always the world is all
surrounds you and you guys just black
out and you wake up tight whoa like
we're back in Toronto please and you're
in some weird like serene very sterile
white room giant window and you look out
the window
it's the my background real quick by the
way I should pause here we need to do
all of our things
oh yeah I'm we're not gonna get through
half of this I also need to figure out
how we can extend the donation cuz we're
do it one hundred and fifty one percent
of our original goal if we get to a
thousand that would be I have $1,000 to
first though we need a doctor evil
monologue who wants to do dr. Evil's
monologue from the first movie okay cam
give us the monologue probably gonna
find it wait okay so wait we're on the
moon that means Goldfinger is gone
because Goldfinger was never really real
yeah everything is reboot sorry okay
okay
just a minute minute all right we're
taking a moment to catch up here it's
the group it's the group therapy scene
oh he's he's like full full changing and
he's wearing drew he's Drake wait is
that my drape necklace I think I gave
that to you right I've like five Drake
necklaces you go one oh hold on hold on
we have we've lost our prop again hold
on my prop you mean your animal you want
me to win if I just hold Kure up I think
they have been distracted by dog okay
all right hey you have to pay your dog
was running away from you we are not
going it was sprinting to try to not be
a part of this adventure okay here we go
dues me a dues for real give it to me
doctor we ready yeah the details of my
life are quite inconsequential very well
where should I begin my father was a
relentlessly self-improving boulangerie
owner from Belgium with low-grade
narcolepsy and upon Shawn for anal sex
my mother was a 15 year old French
prostitute named with webbed feet my
father would womanize he would drink he
would make outrageous claims like he
invented the question mark sometimes he
would accuse chestnuts of being lazy a
sort of general LeMay Lemay's malaise a
sort of general malaise that only the
genius possess and the asain
meant my childhood was typical summers
in Rangoon
Lu's lessons in the spring we'd make
meat helmets if I was insolent I was
placed in a burlap bag and beaten with
reeds pretty standard clearly at the age
of 12 I received my first scribe at the
age of 15 as our oestrogen named Vilma
ritualistically shaved my testicles
there really is nothing like a shaven
scrotum at the age of 18 I went off to
evil school as they say is history
everyone just just to get a big cameo
from Diego that's a give Diego a very
give me a one minute add 4 Doritos and
Pepsi oh you wanna you actually want to
do do you want to do 5-hour energy
protein shots we can see a little bit
this is the worst are you kidding me
people you think people want to sit
listen to me talking about protein shots
Elliot do you remember the the 5-hour
energy protein shot those things wrecked
your gastro system yeah i watch you guys
all day and do a bunch of them what am I
supposed to do
talk about Doritos and Pepsi like heat
like Wayne does in Waynesboro oh I'm
going to go to the bathroom while this
is happening okay I'm not gonna do a
full minute because I don't think of
people I'll be quick okay take your time
don't worry I'm not sure okay
all right hon god this is so hard
I hate improv okay we're not selling you
know listen I would never sell my soul
wait I have to get this perfectly
straight wait
I would never sell my soul just for
money and then I need pizza and I need
Pizza Hut and Doritos sounds real good a
better job than I am I know I mean you
really want me to do a whole minute of
trying to not beat you already it's not
that hard it's not that okay
everyone else bring up all-star everyone
grab all-star cuz we can't play all-star
it's disgusting frankly what people
would do for a dollar you know what I
mean I can't just chug vodka and
honestly my opinion is lowered of
anybody who would do something like that
Jameson actually please sponsor us cause
this [ __ ] is expensive house and home
beautiful you crushed it is everybody
have all star up I'm wait I'll wait I'll
wait for a long I but but right now
we'll go back to the scene you guys
looking out this window you're on the
moon base camera one away so everyone
bring up all star okay oh yeah lyrics to
all star and and I'll lead it off to
give you guys an idea okay
we're gonna do one word at a time we'll
go in one what can we do one minute one
line at a time sorry one like primary
color line I don't know what
means primary colors and then we'll go
in orthogonal directions once direction
what word was that one that you came up
with it's that it's a real word I know
that because of sodoku fog and all yes
clockwise is great let's do clockwise
Chloe scream then wait I haven't had god
damn it Chloe Oh is there an ad oh I'll
oh don't worry if I make any money for
ads I don't know if that works that way
but if it doesn't know obviously donate
but I don't know how to fix that Yeah
right
I don't I genuinely don't know if we
start with me then it'll be cam Chloe
Elliott and then Ilana okay we're doing
a read automatic reading of all saw
spectrum a song chat give me an accent
to do it interesting somebody once told
me the world is gonna roll me I ain't
the sharpest tool in the shed Kim she
was looking kind of dumb with her finger
and her thumb in the shape of an L on
her forehead well the Years start coming
and they don't stop coming fed to the
rules and I hit the ground running
Elliot
Haley it's muted oh god didn't make
sense not to live for fun your brain
gets smart but your head gets dumb so
much to do and so much to see so what's
wrong with taking the back streets
you'll never know if you don't go you go
you'll never shine if you don't glow
glow yes
guitar sliding hey now you are an all
star get your game on go play hey now
you are a rock star get the show on get
paid and all that glitters is gold only
shooting stars break I think we want to
keep going or gonna do this okay I wanna
get a loan against no more alone against
more hey it just does not everybody know
every single line to this yeah this
complete trash I love it was all the
lyrics like we needed like we didn't
know what the lyrics to the ABC is if
you could use a a B Zed's up here in
Toronto Oh in Canada everything's just a
little bit different up here Chloe Chloe
did we pass 75845 oh okay $70 I didn't
even see that so guys we are I think we
can hit 1k easy something an honor of
Cat in the Hat we all now have to speak
in rhyme for five minutes
oh Christ I had to do this for D&D
campaign we'd speak in rhyme for five
minutes and I gotta say it caused a lot
of shame
I completely forgot about this the indie
boy in Chloe's chat just said Ilana open
for Smash Mouth at prom I literally did
do a DJ set that opened for smash
Connick wanna crawl yeah I completely
forgot that I did that orange with that
huge fan of the DC character that
symbolized by that the eggs oh my god
we're not gonna I'm not gonna do it one
day do you look behind you what are you
doing here that's that okay
who is that are we on the moon still
yeah you're on the little baby Axl Rose
[Laughter]
it's me Austin Powers Oh check it out I
bloom like flowers if you're Austin
Powers and I'm Austin Powers screwed
myself for a rhyme bollocks then we're
both Austin Powers powers can rhyme with
powers and flowers like to shag myself
be good for my health don't think it's a
good idea to shag thyself don't think it
would be very good for your health
good just using my rhymes no here's the
situation
I know this up my stream a lot back in
the day this is like ten minutes of
having this weekend drunk it's not fun
here's the situation there's no place is
perfect sanitation we're on the moon
guess what it might be gone soon
Austin Powers his son Scott he's taken
over and if you think he's good he's not
Scott is dr. Evil's son have you seen
these movies like even one that's what I
meant to say babe hmm he's gonna blow up
the moon and the media's will come down
and reign upon earth and spread doom
wait I thought the problem was a brain
tumor maybe I'm gettin wrong maybe this
is a rumor you are correct sir
but this is a part you need this is the
part of that you're trying to get parts
of his brain in order to stabilize all
his mind and characters it's very
complicated
wait his brain is in the moon you need
to set your story straight and soon no
you've already got a parfait what a long
way you have to go way friend I've got a
question again lacks in Irish we have to
defeat someone on the moon or it's going
to explode which naturally would be bad
for me swamp witch as an ogre I do not
want yeah the thing is you've already
got the parfait the next piece of your
mind or it'll be bye-bye it's a good day
okay got it
sounds like Alana as Irish Shrek is
great thank you I really appreciate that
let me see if I can pop Hey
we have to get over there we're gonna
have to race across the moon okay we
should do it soon okay Austin Austin
number two how do we get back to earth I
don't know if I can handle another
tractor the thing is cats we can't so
get that through your brain or you can
just scan skin and go insane okay is my
shag wire we're gonna race it across the
moon's surface to get to the police and
as the button job disarm the bomb that
will explode in the moon okay so because
we're all so suffocating now that were
on the moon and we can't base I'm going
to think about relocating so let's you
know get into is there a building nearby
that we can get into in a race I think
we've hit five minutes guys okay yes
everyone get in my car let's race across
the moon it has remarkable now the
surface of the Moon looks like just like
Southern California guess what it's not
cheese I'm trying okay so we are
currently getting into your car yes get
in my car the shag wha how many so how
many seats does the shag wha have it's
there's a lot of us here at this point
to Austin's which Austin sits in the
front are they both sitting on each
other's laps I'm probably Oh
rolled off for you baby okay roll roll
as standard d6 and I roll a d6 camera
alright brother all right
just d66 just that I'm just a regular d6
what'd you get
alright see the things you go to five I
go to one but it's in the shape of the
Union Jack
which is far more Austin Powers oh he's
not wrong
you're not wrong Austin hold on before
we get in the shag waar I just noticed
there's a a refrigerator you're on the
moon that's fully stocked with beer I'm
gonna go grab one for the road please be
right back Jules by far the best brand
of beer are we in the car you're in the
car okay I'm up across the surface of
the Moon I'll make sure the surface of
the Moon Brandon let me have it
Brennan let me have this let me have
this Brandon let me have this is the one
thing I have okay
all right so I'm gonna turn up the
volume okay okay all right they didn't
have any Molson's but you know what they
had we'll have to do okay I'm ready mama
just killed a man all right skip ahead
guys I need everyone to hang headbang
and ready in three two one
[Music]
just gotta get out just gotta get right
out of you honestly our pitches were
probably too perfect we're gonna get
copyright strikes across the board we
just sang it too well you know I mean a
missile hits the car a bunch of moon
Raiders kind of zip and by you and it's
a race off oh they have they have spikes
on their car and on the side they're
trying to just skewer up against it and
you just see the reflective but Elliott
has a dog this story line and the last
both involved race what what what race
no oh because of the Nazi race maybe a
Nazi sympathizer not sure I don't
appreciate it what do you guys do about
these cars no correct Irish in this in
this role play which means is but if he
also definitely hates foreigners and the
English connection hate Austin Powers
wreck would vote and we know it car bomb
on the shag war yeah look I don't like
him but he's got some good ideas I just
I wish I could do it like that which is
always Irish I dislike that he's so
animated and has a personality but I do
think that everyone should stay out of
my swamp it's so softer it's really hard
Shrek and the rest of the Irish they
just want to be left alone they just
want for themselves it's a simple demand
but the awesome powers of the world
refused to just back the [ __ ] up and
that's where we got where we are today
exactly Thank You Elliott i apprec--
that really means a lot to be heard if
we can get to I will say $1,000 which
would be amazing anyone near that
there's gonna be a battle royale where
all the characters are gonna try to kill
each other you're saying if we hit a
thousand we had a thousand there's gonna
be a Mike Meyers battle royale also I'm
supposed to do so what do you guys want
to do the cards anybody want to do
something okay
Shrek has no concept of what a [ __ ]
car is yeah which is like a huge
roadblock for me
I think I'm terrified I'm very confused
in this vehicle don't know what's going
on so I feel like I don't know that I
can help that much I'm going to you know
being terrified I'm gonna try to jam the
twigs I carry with me in into their
their wheels I'm gonna throw twigs just
throw them right into the trail at their
cars where do you pull these twigs from
I've got like a little you know like a
fanny pack from the swamp I carry twigs
and some frogs and some onions yeah okay
anybody else want to try anything
against the vehicle that's gotta be like
some kind of watchin you know add Chloe
can you roll with these for me one yeah
this one oh you're lucky I got a six man
I got a two so yes this long one of the
songs the town's it's just they start
singing along with you and the words are
so beautiful they sing along and they
don't notice it
[Music]
we have a free dice for Elana right now
perfect timing thank you so I have that
means I have five dice in total I use my
two extra they don't stay right they
don't stack they you can if you want
them you can use them if you want I'm
gonna assume that every time I use the
dice that I get it is going off to that
so right now I have five guys okay I'm
rolling six oh four two so that means my
twigs what's that noise
audio I think it's gone okay so Mike
twigs yeah what do you do what do you do
I pull my twigs out with my fanny-pack
that everyone knows that Shrek has don't
worry about it and I throw them right as
hard as I can as Shrek in a lot of
terror so this is very fast and rapid
into the spokes of one of the cars that
we are racing against the way you do
that and it just immediately breaks down
there's a cool flip the world turns into
slow-motion you start to see another
glitch turns into slow motion and it
just slams against the ground and
explodes but of course it's space so you
can't hear it
hmm because it's sound waves all I can
hear is Wayne you're still in the shag
wire Shack where goes into another
facility that's like a cool slide and
you just be a giant button on the side
of the wall says deactivate moon
explosion oh [ __ ] okay but I felt like
it didn't really work that well yeah I
mean you guys are about to go up
yep what are you cats doing and he goes
front forward and out of out of Austin
Powers two's nipples you see guns I have
low nipples normally nipples are up here
right okay so you don't oh my god it
wasn't really Austin Powers that's not a
man it's a fembot baby all right
and Austin Powers to start shooting guns
high-caliber breasticles and and what do
you guys do first I request to never say
breasticles again you know what tipped
me off was the fact that we were already
with Austin Powers and then another
Austin Powers showed up the only thing
to do is a seductive dance just
realizing there's two movies with my
dance in them but all the Austin Powers
films and which one oh yeah you get a
ring hey it's me basil expedition
expedition I don't think that's really
battle I think that's another fembot
you're not the real basil sorry sorry
I've had a lot of Bailey's today oh my
god Bailey's right I do with ice at four
o'clock in the afternoon I buy that so
what I'm saying is you had an excellent
idea Austin maybe you need to seduce
Austin Powers just suck out his mojo so
everyone's to join together and dance
and then it goes away what do you guys
do
give me dance moves everybody give me
dance I'm being so hard I'm gonna do my
dieter dance moves from sprocket what do
I do I don't know that shrek is a fan of
dancing all I can really do is replicate
what I've seen because I'm not a dancer
I just want to be alone in my swamp
[Music]
[Laughter]
with my white t-shirt
hopefully I also have substance some
kind of liquid in my fanny pack that
would be sad when wearing and I'm your
mom bag thank you and I'm just going to
open it and just pour it on myself as
these happens in the Shrek films at some
point I think yes so it was on the place
then I'm trying to provide just
background music Alleluia
I think it might be Flashdance but I
don't know what it is Flashdance
I thought the fire thing just seems like
one very long ship we appreciate that
you tried but basically yeah I've poured
water on myself because I only know what
I have seen I'm really small-town guy
Irish you know we don't get out a lot
great what is everybody else dance what
is their dance so I my very groovy 60s
stereo play magic carpet ride by
Steppenwolf and then I unbutton my shirt
reveal my very manly chest hair yeah
yeah and then do that also purses was
like you know that with the sexy foxes
thing he does mm-hmm
I I'm actually watching them on the
stream so I can yeah he's doing like you
know it's it's pretty sexy yeah sexy Fox
though okay nailed it Chloe do you have
anything sexy in your bag of arsenal
probably not why I did my shrinking you
didn't see much me yeah she died she won
real hard okay you swing it was alright
Mike Myers what do you got dad
I'm gonna do my character my very
popular Saturday Night Live character
dieter from the sprocket sketch it's
sort of a German kind of expressionist
thing you know kind of cut all over the
place a lot of beat bop boop okay
krautrock sort of thing I think it might
just work so Flashdance is playing the
bullets are spewing out of you know his
his nips and you guys just are all
dancing now here's the thing everybody
at the same time roll your body I want
to say roll your body and roll your
heart because you're putting so much
into this thank you I have extra dice
thanks to doc doc wraith Alana gets an
extra die yeah so body I'll roll first
three two six one Mitch I hit body yeah
I've got a six every time I go to six so
you guys are dancing we're smashing miss
Austin Powers him but he's slowly
glitching out he can't handle all the mo
Braden do do the date do the move do you
remember how the fembot moves what how
does she do it their head describe it to
me it's just like her head glitch us out
and then she just hit her head explodes
really yeah and the head explodes Mike
Myers in spews mojo I don't remember the
song very well
maybe it's how it goes basically yeah
yeah okay we got it
so all I really did was again just pour
water on myself
yes but they really did the truth like
that okay good okay excellent yes that's
the exactly what I was going for as
Irish Trek the Mojo spews all over
everyone and by the way guys we're kind
of into our third act I'm gonna speed it
up because I know people also if we can
get a hundred and twenty five dollars we
will hit a thousand and that will be our
final goal so 125 that'd be incredible
because you guys might go and you see a
sign and it just says I'm skipping over
your world Chloe sorry all right I'm
gonna have my guitar then you wake up
yeah you have your turn
you wake it up in I didn't field
Illinois's correct okay um blue state or
red state depending and lording over you
is a doctor does looks kind of creepy Oh
God
who are you who are you I'm dr. Loomis
you need to get out of here
wait dr. Loomis from hold on a second
the Halloween movies yes it is Halloween
how did you know you need to get out of
here Mike Myers my name is Mike Myers I
escaped from the moon are you talking
about me or different Mike Myers
apparently this has Haddonfield Illinois
you what do you talk you're Mike Myers
killed anyone before
have you ever killed your sister before
um I don't feel comfortable answering
that but you you might have seen me on
you know Saturday Night Live and you
know several successful film franchises
i'vei've grossed over four billion
dollars internationally you
so Mike Myers Mike Myers he pulls out a
cigarette likes it how do you think
people smoke no takes a long drag wait
Ellie have you ever seen the way Brandon
selects a cigarette no I've seen whole
Star Trek's he puts a I'm sorry I made
fun of you you're just unique I thought
that you ate experience which is it I
you know as a person no I think I don't
smoke she's right horseman they smoke
like that good [ __ ] sorry doctor you
seem to have me confused with someone
else
also your neighbor Mike who are you
Michael Myers
I know semi-retired Canadian actor Mike
Myers no you're not you know what this
sounds kind of like a who's on first
situation what's the problem who are you
I'm listen I just found out from anyone
Michael Myers is here at all wait wait
Aurora Illinois in 1978 no Haddonfield
listen doctor I'm not too worried about
this we killed a [ __ ] dragon like an
hour his brain in and you just see the
doctors [ __ ] dead
you're an all-star another one that
doctors had just exploded like mines
gonna explode if I don't get this tumor
out real soon I understand yeah I tried
to get a shark mosque but it didn't
arrive in time fresh prints checking his
doorstep because I send him a Michael
Myers mask yeah I really tried to get a
Shrek one no luck no luck so Michael
Myers
she's a dinner plate he's just he's
standing there and he's a hunk of man
right he's a burnin love they said and
said Oh some mass of meat nice and he's
got a big dick he's naked nobody knows
why yeah you got a white mask over his
dick though it's weird it's William
Shatner's dick and what do you guys do
you're facing Michael Myers we'll go in
a circle cam you can start going
straight and just messes up maybe wait
no hang on hang on maybe try and shoot
him with my 9-millimeter automatic seems
like a good idea yeah yeah you got a gun
this little time yeah it's very heavy
asset if someone doesn't give in or
anything else we can hit that goal and
make their lives easier
it's Michael Myers we did have a
ThighMaster available and I also have my
sweetness okay so okay cam you're gonna
doodle chop no I'm gonna use my
automatic which I okay you're gonna pull
out your gun which guns always working
it's Michael Myers all right and Chloe
what do you do I'm gonna pull out my
Fender Stratocaster
thank you thank you beautiful white
gorgeous geez be Winfrey quit he is
gonna kill you for making her walk sir
Prince oh yeah sorry
sorry I wrote another quest for another
stream that's going on right now and I
made them walk a lot but calc witty
however all right you guys Chloe you
bring out your fender what do you want
to do with this fender oh I'm not I'm
just gonna play the [ __ ] out of it
stairway to heaven real good okay so
you're just gonna throw them away all
right Shrek what are you gonna do what
are you gonna play a very calming melon
yeah yeah okay what kind of weapon does
Michael Mayer just easy just using his
hands or does he have his knife he
doesn't have a knife okay all right so I
was struck and I'm sorry sorry sorry
Andrew all right good no I was gonna say
we're 75 dollars away from like an
all-out brawl sorry sorry to interrupt
okay you're fighting your friend I am
going to Irish wreck pull onions out of
my fanny pack and throw them directly
into the knife in the hopes that they
will burst and then you know really like
get into his eyes yeah I got that with
the onions it's true yes using layers as
weapons it's us I really can't even I
can't even try to do Scottish it never
works I just go Irish every time I'm
sorry to two separate cultures and
countries yes they're all the same
really we're in America now so cam
identifies as Irish and I think I'm more
Irish primarily is a Londoner but yeah
Irish is my favorite I don't know all I
hear is identify as a loser
Revolutionary War I heard it I am white
yeah
I like several kinds of Europeans I'm
like Irish and Scottish European in my
blood that's crazy
99.9% United Nations
thanks to 23andme I can say it like 1%
Asian I always wanted to be I'm gonna
say it
Cameron you don't sound like that I'm so
sorry about this point is I'm so sorry
all I did was throw an onion at the
knife in the hopes that it would then
you know squirt onion juice on him and
make him cry which I feel like Michael
Myers would be like a really tough thing
to deal with
yeah okay Mike Myers semi-retired what
do you do well I think I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to reason with this other Mike
Myers because you know it's sort of a
it's a nature versus nurture thing I
think I can really level with them
they're like for example me Mike Myers I
was I was born up in Ottawa Canada and
you know came from a good household and
you know I it all worked out quite well
for me whereas this American Mike Myers
born into the most violent country in
the world hey you went down the wrong
path I just I just want to talk to him
let him know that uh you know if he had
been born in Canada things would have
been different
you're all [ __ ] useless none of this
is good can you have you do you know who
Michael Myers is and I think a song we
know that doesn't work either not that
onions is better but [ __ ] me right I
think once he sees that we have the same
name and I've got seven yeah it's like
seven MTV Movie Awards like the ultimate
an accomplishment over four billion
dollars global box office net I think
you can see that uh you know we're not
so different after all right
for heart area so I got I got four heart
dice let's give it a go by the way guys
were so close to hitting that one case
yeah that didn't work he he didn't
listen to reason
Oh shocking Oh would have known that
Michael Myers wouldn't have listened to
your impassioned speech about Canada so
you talked about Canada show him your
your statues and everything in Michael
Myers he was not impressed
even though he pulled a knife on me
shoves the knife right into your stomach
if I die everyone dies right cuz you're
in my brain hold on maybe you're not
dead yet okay yeah survive just an aside
your body and pulls out your intestine
Oh remember free health care in Canada
so they could probably fix it at a very
low cost and cam can you roll your tech
for me no he makes a lasso and lasso is
the gun and then goes up to you and with
it starts choking you to death with Mike
Meyers primes large intestine Khloe what
do you do I'm doing my stairway to
heaven my dog actually I ain't gonna
happen just have to be the Cat in the
Hat now I don't never seen can a hat
well you gonna come up with something
big character change the catnap thank
you very much boy we're 50 away from a
thousand guys alright so you you are now
the cat in the action just going to use
you know if in doubt that Russian isn't
that Russian Oh God
I don't know about my Russian it's been
a minute one get me into it get me into
it
it'll be a dress like yes yes we don't
like these okay cat you're going to be
fine
yes I am get your hat also look God
joins so does that does that mean I'm
playing captain hat and women hat you
transformed there was a glitch in the
matrix there's been all these kinds of
glitches okay I want you to give me a
body roll during the stream by the way I
think yeah yeah absolutely if I got bits
and I will don't so yes I hit a six and
I in a scratch big scary man releases he
releases awesome power from the grip and
some days back oh [ __ ] what else right
across his eye and you see through the
mask you see this kind of disfigured
face face actually isn't that this
figure to be honest but you see piercing
through it and then all of a sudden
onions fly through the air the show dude
can you roll for body me roll for body
one five four one
no six Alana have dice re-roll well I've
been getting rid of them technically I
have an extra three but once I've been
using them I've been just yeah getting
rid of so yeah my total is 11 I got one
five four one one five
thousand and five which is even better
lle it's an extra dice thank you guys so
much we had a thousand dollars I'm gonna
I'm gonna speed this moly
after as you're throwing these onions at
him Michael Myers is just leading
through them all yeah happening cuz this
mosque I thought that might be a problem
you know the mask is just reflecting all
the on you know de yeah there's nothing
happen but still
aroma the general lot of it does start
to make him cry you see Michael Myers
break down and it's weird because this
this is a man who isn't supposed to have
empathy but it's because his tear ducts
have been restricted as a little
technically human I don't know yeah
exactly so when he starts to cry all
these emotions flood in he's not just
crying for now he's crying for
everything that he has there yeah
you coulda had my life Mike by the way
you're still holding your own yeah you
didn't have to cut me open like a
[ __ ] ten of uh you know Ontario
cheese over here sure it's like it looks
like poutine down there on the grounds
again he's crying I caught it we have
another two hundred dollar donation oh
my goodness Kappa Kappa part of me
wonders if that's my actual mom and also
if it is she fat named Joyce Cass I
think it is I think it is she that's her
name in Latin in her like secret
languages cabassa
mom escapes yeah I think it is I don't
want to person give her credit for it
but if it is thank you yes thank you
incredible guys you have been doing it
so well in green get a phone call I'm
your razor you flip it open how all it's
me this is Canadian actor Mike Meyer
semi-retired Mike - how are you doing
it's me
basil exposition he left he journeyed to
the to the wilderness of Arabia now
maybe is mostly desert what wilderness
are you talking about there's a tree
every now and then and guess what well
just get on with it basil okay there's
been lots of glitches in the system what
we've realized is it's because Mike
Myers you're such a good actor you've
had all these characters living in your
mind all this time seven MTV Movie
Awards right yeah I know you keep saying
that
yeah never a Kids Choice Award have you
ever been slimed I've been slimed
believe me I've been slimed have you
seen have you seen the video of Katy
Perry getting slimed it's hilarious
she's a beautiful American actress that
Katy Perry true but the video of hoping
slimed
is hilarious anyways you look it up
maybe what do I have you know less
pressing matters all I'll Google that my
guts were cut open by a serial killer
Castle so was he still alive
perhaps I don't know right now I'd
really like if you could direct me to
the nearest Canadian hospital something
else your brain is being overloaded yeah
my bodies are real a real mess right now
and in order for you to save the world
there needs to be a battle right now
between all these personalities in your
mind there can only be one left at the
end so murder all the other
personalities only one of you may live
good all these people that
I've just been on this journey with who
are characters that I played throughout
my long and profitable career you're
asking us to all kill each other yes
it's all a metaphor for capitalism I
just looked at Katy Perry being slimed
it's a girl I'll say this I might you
know I might not be in good shape for
fighting right now on account of the
brain tumor and the mortal wound in Mike
stomach
it's got my my guts looking like poutine
but if any of y'all skills me you die
too cuz you're living in my break just
want to let you know ring ring don't
worry everyone thank you appreciate that
okay now there's a Stairmaster in play
do we want to throw a judo stand master
well we have to roll for who gets this
they're mad
okay so we're brother wants to give it
to me that um so what are we just all
rolling one six yeah yeah I don't I hit
this I think it's a one it's a one I got
up to one twice so it was meant to be I
can afford Elliot what are you wrong
you're muted I lost my mind which
attribute am i rolling
I just rule a decent role they do a
single d6 a single oh boy oh boy let's
have a yeah that's gonna be a five oh I
got a buddy oh thank god oh so now we're
on another d6 cam and Elliot are rolling
off this is it the biz is it a drama I
got our four three Elliot auto kill so
I'm gonna see who's getting it first
things first Elliot which is kind of
what we want I guess yeah thank God I
can't really use it right now on account
of having been stabbed in the guts
Chloe's dream lately I want everyone to
point to who they want to battle at the
count of three
Oh Oh God what yes oh dude I don't want
to battle any what I like like like
Ilana if you want to do Chloe just make
it okay did everyone see you on Chloe
stream okay the count of three point to
who you want to battle one two three we
all want to battle you British
wait are you need to catch up on stream
we were rebelling against the fighting
word the fighting the DM no I went I
want to Chloe technically yeah oh my oh
oh I see what you're doing
got it so a lot of wants to fight me and
we're all trying to fight and everyone
else uranium yeah
[Applause]
first thing yet first thing we'll do is
Alana Shrek sorry didn't mean to call
you thank you and didn't mean deploy
your axe and [ __ ] mate what do you want
to do to Wayne and then Wayne what are
you gonna do against Shrek
yeah listen Chloe it's not personal I
just felt like Shrek would really
dislike Wayne I'm gonna go with also a
throwing fart in the hopes that I can
make Wayne giggle hard enough to be
distracted by any fighting so you know
I've got unlimited gas I am going to
again try to just turn my back side
towards Wayne and be flatulence I love
it I like it because it's not a body
move anymore it's a heart move
interesting okay three dice so you get
three dice I've been using them as I've
gotten them I don't think about anymore
since my last program okay
three give me three rolling my three
dice four six four okay Chloe I'm gonna
give you a chance to rebuttal for but
okay this part wash your way and it's a
good one
it's like a wet juicy so loud there was
some flaps
my cake went wild one of Wayne's friends
pops up before he does the roses wait I
love you dude I'm out here no you don't
I love you dude I know no I love you
let's say I was actually gonna call on
Garth funny enough okay you wanna do my
Garth yeah I suppose all right cool I'm
calling my god okay geez who arrives in
the mirth mobile I'm just doing it well
listen we gotta fight this fat green
dude right right chuckles me excellent I
think I got a handle okay all right so
they're allowed to just summon another
dude well I mean the background could
have someone to donkey or pass us I'm
got your drum set
all right let's Jim what do you want to
do what are you trying to do so now
we're gonna blast the [ __ ] out of Shrek
with my band and I mean I don't know if
you've seen Dana Carvey okay I'm gonna
hammer on the drums you want a place
with Alice Cooper right so you are
trying to reject the fart with sound
waves from yeah it's like Harry Potter
that's fair okay all right you provide
all right shut up Harry Potter Wow oh
thank you really
you can send your busy man you're busy
man yeah we like that guy okay
okay so Chloe I need you to roll me you
know that way it's it's even here right
before we roll Wayne's World Wayne's
World
party time okay oh I gotta say I'm gonna
say so gotta say is we see an epic clash
we see the flatulence float towards and
then we see this epic sound waves of the
drums is they and they just hit each
other and it's going back and forth and
it's an epic battle it's like Voldemort
works against Harry and I need you both
to roll off 1d6
against each other like is there a way
that I can save you I believe you okay
bro again we gotta roll again the fart
gets stronger the beats get stronger
they swelled foxy ladies happening now
to another six sorry
everyone's who's wearing headphones oh I
got four okay so this fart just
penetrates the sound waves I feel really
lucky with success I'm just using the
using the dice roller on Google I think
it wait
it penetrates through these records
actually secretly the devil and it's
slowly as it as it kind of hits your
face it slowly dissolves it away and
it's like that scene from Raiders from
Indiana Joe and raises a little stock
Raiders of the Lost Ark and you just
melts away and Wayne dissolves and dies
wait before can I request yes what is
your last words Monkees literally fly on
my butt okay I have a tumor as as you're
dissolving down everything the last
thing we see is a close-up of your Botox
and monkeys fly out of it and Garth is
holding you in his arms crying for his
lost friends and he dissolves away as
well Shrek you're on the board Elliot
cam you guys want to face the DM yeah I
want to face basil's too - I want to
fight he seems to be the ones got me
into all this
you see riding up in a really cool
British car Aston Martin Range Rover and
you get that on the arguably not cool
definitely cover Scott Austin Lucas yeah
T
No okay I'm offended by that one even
though you were great in the movie
cabaret with Liza Minnelli [ __ ]
classic I do not like what you've done
to me today it's been nothing but pain
and suffering my guts are still just I
can't call it's like spaghetti down
there help you out I've been doing this
for you this whole time I'm trying to
save the world it's like a can of
spaghetti
it's the Canadian version of SpaghettiOs
down there Oh over here we have complex
and crackers
Marmite because of my faculty Basel I
what do you do - Basel I am what do you
do as well
Bazley been my friend for many years
ma'am but you know what turning on your
friends it's just not groovy man
ouch baby what very ouch who said I
turned on you I'm trying to save the
world
Austin danger powers that is my middle
name
but you know what I like to live
dangerously and if dad says we have to
turn against you then dad says we got to
turn against you man yeah what do you do
judo chop swinging through what do you
got what do you got for me real Mike
Myers well I may have I may have used my
my seven MTV Movie Awards earlier in an
unsuccessful attempt to lure the dragon
out of its lair but you know being such
a successful Canadian actor as I am I
got a few more Awards up my sleeve I'm a
four-time Canadian Comedy Awards winner
and you know of course I have those four
Awards with me right now Lee naturally
so I'm gonna I'm gonna throw the four
awards that I got from the Canadian
Comedy Awards right up basil's head
right now and see if it hits him or his
stupid car and Michael Myers no sorry
not Michael Myers Austin Powers what did
you do judo chop judo judo chop okay so
this is happening give me a body roll
both of you
body roll Oh actually it's detected
using something oh jeez that's even
worse for me we tack on good buddy I got
two dice let's uh let's see what
everybody ah
no dice for me buddy I guess that's more
awards just thrown into the [ __ ]
gutter
wait what you've got you got no dice oh
no I got a two and a five but that's no
six give them guys they can now this
looks like a by pdn for Canadian
semi-retired actor Mike Meyers seem that
way killed by one of my own characters
not even by one of my own characters by
one of my own characters called
characters coming bezos way how does it
how does it do camp pretty [ __ ]
terrible but you can kill me GM but the
cause of peace and love will continue
man he grabs the judo chop rips off your
arm Oh broken bone
he stabs real Michael Myers table jeez
like I'm so wounded I have so many
things wrong with my body right now in
the open wound he stabs them cuz that
what please take me to a Canadian
hospital for free health care and now
we're in America now and just rips you
in half with the arm can Michael Myers
you sit there not Michael Myers there's
so much in my brain right now Mike Myers
Prime Mike Myers Prime is dead Wayne is
dead and slowly bleeding out we were
doing so good
we see Austin Powers without an arm have
any last innuendos could really use a
hand here you go there it is death he
slowly he dies not only because of his
wound but also because of the bad pun
and he looks at Shrek Shrek this is all
your fault buddy sure will be great I
did well and I shouldn't be stretched
yeah Shrek even if you might be a Nazi
sympathizer
maybe we're not sure you are the only
Mike Myers to ever exist thank you you
shake Mike Myers are Basil's hands and
the world goes dark
and you wake up again and we see another
beautiful Canadian sky okay we zoom down
run that same hill overlooking Toronto
pollution nothing no pollution some
great game studios driving in that city
and what was mike myers prime now sits
Shrek and Shrek is looking out on this
world and he decided to go home and tuck
his kids into bed I have older Mike I
have kids
do you need a dice roll on whether I
think he's taking over my life it's
several time award-winning I don't have
to stats up yeah Mike Myers here seven
time seven time I'm just gonna roll
maybe maybe we'd roll heart on this on
whether or not I successfully took the
children into bed does that seem yes
okay so if we're rolling hard it's only
three so let's roll it
there we go that's five and then three
so I well okay now I need to roll that
one to five three four okay so as you're
checking the kids and you accidentally
you would think that one but I still got
a 500 my bad
Shrek never should have left the swamp
as we there's a circle star swipe that
goes into the screen as Shrek is now
taking over Mike Myers's life and that
is the end of the Mike Myers verse I
don't I'm really sorry
but the happy ending is who raised
$1,200 and also we all knew from the
beginning really that the only constant
in life really is Shrek so it just
reinforced what we had already know
somebody once told me the world was
gonna roll me and that is know try to
sing all-star even though there's
latency it's gonna sell sounds great
three two so what's wrong with taking
the back streets
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love seven viewers immediately notice
10 gone now thank you so much for
donating thank you guys so much for
watching we'll probably do some more TT
RPGs like this hopefully
Thank You Elliot so much for coming on
Elliot
Internet today TV on YouTube and then at
Elliot et Cie on Twitter run thank you
and thank you so much for coming on
where can people find you I'm just uh
it's very very complicated but it's just
Alanna in the middle of Charizard Charl
Anna's on
Charl ah that's fine you might remember
it's cool it's what I thought about I
dunno it's just hard to say and Brandon
where can people find you not me
oh yeah that's right sorry well hold on
Brandon first and then we'll come back
to you you can find me in Los Angeles
California no specifically be Winfrey on
the things I stream with you sometimes I
stream
I haven't I stream on other people's
channels I don't have my own right
Brandon is on hyper RPG his Twitter and
all of his other stuff is at B Winfrey
Brandon Winfrey like Oprah Winfrey but
not to be with you Tuesday he streams
with me and now Fridays as well some
Fridays and then and then camera uh you
can find me at the Cameron cuff on
Twitter Instagram but more often you can
find me just playing Fifa yes thank you
guys so much for watching thank you guys
we fed so many people today yeah this is
so dumb and so fun 247 percent of your
goal you were so mod I've never done
this before so I didn't know how much to
ask for and you guys it's awesome thank
you turns out a lot of people wanted to
watch some extremely cringy shifted okay
this might be one of the most cringe
things I've actively aware of it the bad
part is not even close to the crank
I know that for a fact and there's the
worst part we didn't play Bohemian
Rhapsody so this will be on the internet
forever no can I get taken down